[Music]
this is a real chance to use sound to
save species from extinction a lot of
these frogs that were working with are
endangered they need our support and
sound can be a tool for conservation the
frog that we are looking for is called
electro hollow exquisite ax the
exquisite spike from frog and it is a
species endemic to this location in
cazuca National Park it is critically
endangered and found nowhere else in the
world
we are building a frog rescue center to
breed these animals in captivity and
reintroduce them the problem is that in
order to effectively conserve this frog
we really need to understand the
behavior the natural history what do
they eat and what do they sound like we
really know very little about any of
this in captive breeding situation calls
and sounds of the environment are
critical to success the males especially
rely on calls in order to help simulate
breeding behavior but not just the calls
we want sounds of water rushing we want
sounds of wind in the trees and things
like that to help artificially immerse
these animals in their environment and
give them everything they need to be
successful
our target our pinus guy dream is to get
wild vocalizations of exquisite because
they've never been heard before and we
don't even know what the frog sounds
like if we do I mean it doesn't get
better than that you're contributing to
the historical record you are building
knowledge and you're contributing to
conservation we know that some frogs
don't make a call but we also do know
that excuse either can make sound there
are some instances where we have
captured an expose de in order to check
its health and it actually will chatter
[Music]
and that opens the possibility that we
just haven't been able to record it yet
[Music]
recording on a river is really difficult
there's no way around it you have to
navigate the sounds of rushing water
usually you can use a landscape to
mitigate geological background sound but
in this circumstance we are right in the
middle of it these frogs like rushing
water
one three we had was that ex cuisine ax
was vocalizing in a different time of
day that we had never surveyed before so
he got up at all hours of the night and
all hours of the day and went into the
rivers in the forest to listen and
record that was really exciting because
what we found out was that they're not
doing what we thought they're doing in
broad daylight in the afternoon I found
three adult excuse EDA in one small pool
below a tiny cascade in the river all
active and swimming and walking on the
bottom I mean these are frogs that live
high up in the canopy it's one of the
highest canopy frogs that live in this
forest so the last place we would have
ever expected to look for a frog would
be under water let alone during the day
for a nocturnal species another possible
hypothesis was that we were already
hearing xqc tikal and we said know it
but and we captured all the sounds we
could in our fieldwork and line them up
to do spectrographic analysis and from
what we can see they're not acoustically
distinct enough to indicate a different
species however there's one interesting
idea that still has a lot of possibility
to it and it's that these frogs are
singing through a different medium not
using the air they're using the water
this is really interesting because we
have rarely ever seen any frogs that
live in the trees staying in the water
except for this species if these frogs
are so comfortable underwater maybe one
of the reasons we haven't heard of it
yet is because they vocalize underwater
that would certainly give them an
evolutionary advantage there's a lot of
acoustic competition in the water to
investigate whether or not h20 was
calling in the water we deployed a whole
series of hydrophones and listen for
hours and hours and hours in many
different locations
one of the most exciting outcomes of
this project is the recording of a sound
underwater that we cannot explain right
now
oh just her gait and again yeah yeah
yeah no whatever this is it's very
interesting there was a consistent
pattern repeated seven or eight times
every minute or so it was really
interesting if it's biological the only
way we can really confirm that is if we
find it somewhere else that we did
Thomas forming a condo a look at I asked
oh he the reprinting very future Veneto
lol Umbro e electricity oh poor poor
area the del agua del agua the soleus de
bajo el agua la huasteca everyone and
once it left the water and ascended the
tripod the noise stopped and look at
this
that looks pretty yeah it's quite
beautiful
I'm gonna feel like also yeah how
perfect the spacing is really says
something that this is most likely
biological although we need to invest a
lot more research to figure out exactly
what is this already the puzzle pieces
are starting to fit together and really
suggests that exquisite of might in fact
be calling underwater
we've recorded the vocalizations of
several endangered frog species here in
the park and I'm really excited to have
contributed to that effort recording any
kind of behavior is really helpful to
conservation that helps us to know what
they need and what we can provide for
them in order to help save them looking
in places at times for things that you
don't expect often can produce really
exciting results we had only read the
books and all the literature and use
those to decide when to go out looking
for things we would have not found
nearly as much as me to discover this
expedition la casita la raza push que
son ran endemic adel parque nacional
Kazuko paraguay no para que no no voy a
la Ossa adam in mere hours aparecer
Nieto Anita motoneuron on staff on a
natural Asia little murky area
podemos aprender algo the river so
splash the anomalies
[Music]
you